Hi there, Ashley here. And I am happy that you are joining me to learn about clear
histamines scavenger by Connor's clinic. So clear histamines scavenger is going to be a great
product to take if you feel like you have high histamine. A good place to start to know if you
have high histamine is to kind of check the foods that you're eating. So these are foods that we'd
want to avoid. They are highest in histamine. Of course, we cannot avoid all histamines. They are
literally everywhere. So by lessening your exposure through your foods would be probably the
best place to start here. So again, reducing high histamine foods in your diet would include some
of these. And I know they're very popular items, but they are the highest. So if you can't eliminate
them, then of course, we'd even more encourage that you take clear histamines scavenger if these
are in your diet just again to help with that. Lessening the histamine load on your system.
So this ingredient list is meant to help reduce the histamine in the tissues. So that would indicate
that there's inflammation present in the tissues. So this product does promote reduction of harmful
histamine accumulation. So some potential indicators for elevated histamine would look like these
symptoms here. So I'll give you a second kind of look over this list. They can look a very general.
So nothing that's like, oh yeah, that indicates high histamine for sure. They're kind of generalized
which can make it a little difficult to know. So again, if you start with eliminating the high
histamine foods, maybe some of these would lessen your symptoms maybe. Or if you do take clear histamine
scavenger, you would notice that some of these symptoms that you may be experiencing would of course
lessen or decrease. So potential benefits of taking clear histamine scavenger would be that it does
support a normal histamine level in our body. It does reduce inflammation to non-allergen exposures.
It can help the body repairly get gut or prevent it from its onset. It can then also support our genes
ABP1 and HNMT. The dosage is really up to you depending on the symptoms. You can start with one or two
and work your way up. If you eat high histamine foods or notice that they are a majority of your
diet, then we definitely would encourage that you take this supplement and then you would want to
take it with your meal. And then of course, if you have genetic variants on your histamine genes,
again, ABP1, HNMT, then we would definitely encourage that you take a histamine scavenger with your
meal as well. But again, these are general and you can also decide based on your symptoms on if you
should increase the dose or not. And oh, as always, we recommend that you run this by your health care
professional. And then you can find clear histamine scavenger on our web store shop.conorsclinic.com.
And you can type it right into the magnifying glass to pull it up. And then we do have even more
additional information on our web store here with this product if you wanted to learn more.
We appreciate you being here and learning about our products. And we thank you for watching this
video. And as always, we will continue to pray for you on your health journey. Thank you again.